attorney turned criminal michael
avenatti is being faced with another
conviction he faces 22 years in prison
after b after being found guilty for
stealing nearly 300 000 from stormy
daniels the media once thought this guy
was a good thing greg what's your take
well you know what i i have to quote red
steez's latest tweet he never appeared
on joe rogan yeah but he appeared on cnn
msnbc just about every media organ that
has been bashing rogan and it validated
fox because fox was right there knew he
was a snake tucker was the first guy to
call him creepy porn lawyer but it's
another example how the generally the
media gets things and people wrong he
was cnn's choice to take down trump uh
there was andrew cuomo there's smilet of
course there's jeff zucker all these
people we don't fall for cads here we
saw and also then they demonized people
like nick sandman but there's a huge
blind spot in the legacy media they
can't see flaws in people that are on
their own team you know maybe that's
true of every team but i i'd like to
think i had my doubts about you when i
first exactly and i proved you wrong you
did prove me wrong in vermont martha
let's take a look at the media's level
along with avenatti
he's out there saving the country you
know what he's a rock star i think
michael avenatti is a beast you're like
the holy spirit you are
all places at all times sitting beside
me right now i'm not gonna let you cheat
you have to guess uh a hint his name is
michael avenatti okay
here's something else michael avenatti
i'd like to meet you sometime over
at dinner you got lucky tonight we're
back with attorney michael avenatti he
is a main player looking ahead to 2020
one reason why i'm taking you seriously
as a contender is because of your
presence on cable news we've done this
it's great martha remember that remember
that thank you
you should be president you should be
president uh you know what i'm just
really happy for stormy daniels because
um he'll have no fury like an adult
pornography
porn okay and she's like no he took my
money right and she's so mad right and
she's like no way and i just love that
she she realized what was going on right
she's like no no no
you called my publisher and said to send
you my advance and she just she nailed
it so good for you good for you stormy
daniels
and i don't see her being you know
entertained by all of those folks on cnn
and like you you know right right is she
the real winner stormy daniel's the real
winner in this whole saga is stormy a
winner i would not go that far
i just can't believe all of those people
that we saw in that montage they're all
either fired you're suspended
i think he might have been poisoned
anybody he did an interview with ended
up leaving
i knew this guy was a chump because i
knew he was desperate because he was
loaded up with debt do you remember in
the very beginning he'd like spun off a
bunch of companies and like screwed a
bunch of investors and then he split off
from his law firm and then he was
getting sued by a shutdown nike so he
right so he kept on trying to build and
build off the back of all these debtors
that he was accumulating and and it
forced him into more desperate things
how do you shake down a porn star while
you're shaking down a president the
ponzi scheme while you're trying to
shake down a supreme court justice just
to think about what how he slept at
night going to bed when you're doing all
these things the man is a maniac and we
all saw it coming so judge from a legal
perspective so 22 years is what he's
possibly facing one charge comes the
mandatory two-year sentence right um how
long do you think he'll be in jail for
or what's going to happen next in the
process well you know it depends upon
the judge i mean i don't know that there
are grounds for a serious appeal here of
course he'll appeal he can't claim an
effective assistance of counsel he was
his own lawyer could he though
[Laughter]
but
which i think was a smart move because
he's very shrewd he can talk and i think
he felt he could intimidate stormy
daniels and it was clear that what he
was doing was he was faking her
signature
re-rerouting these wire transfers and he
kept telling her the publisher isn't
giving you the money i don't know why
meanwhile he's depositing it
he should get some serious state prison
time this is his second felony uh this
and uh although there's there's
mandatory two-year on the on the lower
wire fraud uh but i think that uh he
should get i don't know five to two did
he he was convicted of the nike
shakedown right yes so he's looking at
time for that and for this yes yes so
this is his second spell on the
conversation the wire fraud and then the
impersonator you know the time on this
it'll be consecutive whatever it is
because it's part of the same criminal
uh uh
situation but he'll get jail time he
should get jail time save prison time is
more like it he's like but he's a dirk
bank he this guy is a dirt bike he's a
what the holy spirit he's a dirtbag and
we'll be doing some time with some fan
mail friday up now